It's a real real pleasure to be with you
today to celebrate the pan-european launch
of the new erasmus plus program
– the jewel in europe's crown.
Erasmus it's the eu exchange program
that some european commissioners
love to imagine as a european institution
that can create perfect europeans
Since its start in the late 1980s erasmus
has moved millions of european students
across europe's borders, and in 2021 erasmus plus,
the umbrella term for the eu's education program
that covers the erasmus exchange program,
saw a substantial increase in its budget
from about 14.7 billion euros spread over six
years to 26.2 billion spread over another.
Besides providing opportunities to study abroad
and potentially improving someone's job prospects,
the erasmus exchange program has
often been regarded as one of the
most effective institutions for
producing a pan-european identity,
but whether this actually happens
is much less clear than it seems.
The creation of a european identity through
erasmus has been coined the erasmus effect
if contact between different europeans exist
then a group identity will possibly follow.
However, the problem with this theory is that
erasmus attracts a type of student that is
already less likely to be impacted by erasmus
when it comes to producing a european identity.
Those participating in erasmus are
already likely to identify as european
before their exchange making the
erasmus effect relatively negligible.
Those coming from a lower rung of education,
as a result not able to participate,
are less likely to identify as european
and are more likely to be euroskeptic.
It's not that erasmus doesn't have an effect on
creating a european identity, but the people who
are more likely to be affected by erasmus are less
likely to be in a position where they will be.
However this may also be temporary.
Last wednesday at the state of
the union Ursula von der Leyen
announced the eu's plans for ALMA a european
exchange program targeted towards the unemployed.
The idea of extending european exchange to a
different level besides university education
is not new and it seems like the tide is turning
The netherlands education levels are split
between mbo, hbo, and wo. MBOers usually pursue
vocational education and are more euroskeptic
and WOers usually pursue university and are less.
Naturally WOers were the ones who
usually did the erasmus exchange,
but the amount of MBO students abroad with
help from eu grants has also been increasing.
This increased movement has been encouraged
and Alexander Pechthold, the former dutch
leader of D77 said that MBO students should have
better access to european exchange programs.
Europe is no game for the happy few. It needs to
show that it's absolutely necessary for all of us.
You can also see other examples like Volt
Netherlands explicitly pushing to broaden erasmus
plus for MBO and HBO students as one of their
policy standpoints in the last dutch election.
Evaluations have shown that the early
erasmus plus program was able to
facilitate a european identity among a
sample of vocational students – with 66
feeling more european after and over 72 percent
declaring to have a larger interest in the eu.
With the set goal of reaching 10
million more students, erasmus plus
over the course of 2021 and 2027
is set to focus more on inclusion,
and the new program is doubling the funding for
vocational education from 2.9 million to up to 4.4
Whether this new more inclusive erasmus
budget plus the additional ALMA program
announced this year will actually produce
a larger european identity among europeans
who feel that connection the least
is honestly difficult to determine.
But whether this is part of the european union's
goal of producing a stronger european identity,
that's undeniable.
Our ultimate goal should be
that erasmus is not become
an option but a fundamental
right for all europeans.
This new reinforced robust erasmus plus
will be key to support our model of
society and our european way of life.